I am delighted to be able to announce
the publication of a new book in the
stoicism today selected writings volumes
this is volume 4 coming out in paperback
and Kindle versions just in time for the
holidays if you'd like to give somebody
the gift of stoicism there's a ton of
great essays in here and I'm very proud
of this I'm one of the editors along
with my co-editor Leah goldrick both of
us actually have been involved in this
entire project publishing these two
volumes over the last two years and so
we've now got volume four out I do want
to say something else before I go into
the table of contents and start telling
you all the great stuff that's in here
if you purchase this volume or volume 3
all all of the prophets go to the modern
stoicism organization which is is you
know focused on bringing stoicism to
people worldwide it's a not-for-profit
organization that publishes stoicism
today the blog also puts on stoicon some
stoicon X events these are conferences
that people come to from all over the
world and the stoic weak and stoic
mindfulness and resilience training
course among many other activities that
they engage in so it's a great
organization if you purchase these
you're actually furthering the work of
those organizations or even if you just
want to purchase one get volume four the
newest one now what is in here so these
are essays that were originally
published in the stoicism today blog and
you notice that the table of contents is
divided into a number of different
different really cool subjects we begin
with stoicism and matters of ultimate
importance talking about time talking
about death talking about pain talking
about the view from above then we have a
section on stoic inspiration and
fortitude how do stoics handle things
like Exile or hard truths or how do you
wind up being joyful or dealing with
your setbacks then we have a section on
stoicism for difficult real life
situations with the unduly demanding in
the workplace stoic professionals
stoicism in retail even stoicism and
bullying we also have a part on roles
and family relationships with two great
essays there and then we have two
controversies one of which is focused on
Jordan Peterson and stoicism is the sort
of of things that Peter Peterson is
putting forward compatible with
equivalent to stoicism and there's a lot
of discussion why or why that isn't the
case and then another controversy about
stoicism wrongdoing and evil the second
to last section or part mental health
emotions and therapy we've got some
great essays in there including from
people who found stoicism very helpful
not just as practitioners helping other
people but for their own mental health
Journey towards uh you know more
happiness and resilience then we have a
wrap up stoic potpouri right you know a
bunch of different things thrown
together which include fake quotes
Frederick the great
mindfulness and the musonias Rufus diet
and we finish up with one of the
symposia that we held in the blog
stoicism today about whether stoicism is
something equally useful for men and
women a lot of great authors weighing in
on that very topic so a ton of stuff in
this volume I hope that you'll think
about purchasing it you can go to Amazon
and easily see the table of contents
maybe that will you know give you a
better idea about the specifics in this
work and you know I'll just put in a
pitch if you're going to get stoicism
today volume four why not also get if
you don't have it already the companion
piece stoicism today volume three as
well bundle them together look how nice
they would look together on the
bookshelf so I've said enough here you
can decide for yourself whether you
think that this is a good book for you
to purchase and you know it's available
like I said in paperback form and in
Kindle and if you're buying a copy we
want to thank you in advance not just as
the editors speaking for myself and my
co-editor Leia but also for the modern
stoicism organization whose work you
will be helping and supporting and
furthering by purchasing either of these
great books